bene a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj oggi
siamo su white night white light che in
italiano tradotto proprio così alla
veloce significa una tarda notte
non penso di essere proprio il primo ma
comunque uno dei primi al mondo a
giocarlo di sicuro
entriamo proviamoci perché non illuderci
cosa sto per andare a giocare mi avete
detto che ce ne ho visto un paio di
screenshot ha una grafica spettacolare
adesso andiamo a vedere cos'è un iphone
perfetto linda alle 2 45
se ci vediamo presto alle 23 59 scusa
era troppo tardi e abitano di quanto mi
aspettassi
non sono sicuro ed hanno fatto in tempo
però oddio che è successo cos'è sono due
gambe
allora ok mi sono addormentato sulla
tastiera
mi scaldo netta sulla tastiera ragazzi
che tra la trovata sera anche della
logitech c'è la marca
ok tempo di vedere se il caffè è pronto
bene un computer fantastico ok ma c'è
anche il caso dell'android noi ragazzi è
fantastico ma vorrei che dettagli ciò
non ho mai visto in vita mia un indie
consta grafica qui c'è ma giuro
oddio che è successo ho sentito
rumoreggiava beh no no veramente ragazzi
guardate che grafica non ho mai giocato
un indico si è fatto con gli uniti ma
veramente una cosa assurda
ok bene cosa devo fare e posso sedere
perfetto
login mai password
ho lasciato una nota qui da qualche
parte ecco mi allora user name e
password
ce l'ho io avrei messo fa vj che è
perfetto
bella e ora banane fa vj
iscriviti vaccino non ha idea di che
cosa debba fare quei ragazzi usciamo
subito perché bo bene il computer più
inutile del mondo radio
ok cassetti posso aprire i cassetti
perfetto
bene non c'è nulla il coso dell'android
paula ed io l'ho preso
lo voglio anch'io queste ragazze che si
compra un addio da ragazzi veramente lo
voglio anch'io un android volante lite
dove si compra ragazzi sui ve lo trovo
android volante questo me lo segno che
tra l'altro si è messo a levitare sulla
tastiera non fa niente oddio che succede
che fa che è successo perché è andato
sotto la scrivania perché ti sei nostro
sotto la scrivania che che senso c'è
odio hack la spina siamo andati i
dettagli ragazzi la ventola
no adesso tu mi spieghi perché ti sei
nascosto sotto la scrivania c'è ragazzi
voi non vi capita mai che durante il
giorno mi prende di nascondervi sotto le
scrivanie mesi succede spesso
intanto torna a casa da scuola e ho mia
tolgo la sedia ami fico sotto perché
perché mi viene da nascondermi a caso
perché che succede robert office a ma
non è a casa in un ufficio non l'ho
capita a sta cosa della pasta office ai
wonderware i went dov'è andato un giorno
era era qui è senza un apparente motivo
ha è sparito
ha smesso di tornare a lavoro bene bella
storia mi è piaciuta mi ha
tranquillizzato
mi chiamerà la fotocopiatrice mi son
cagato addosso sentito tipo sembrava
qualcuno che è che chiudesse le porte
tipo va beh noi che dobbiamo fare qui
apriamo tutto c'è niente ragazzino ok ho
sbattuto contro il vetro di potenza
ragazzi non ho idea di che cosa debba
fare in questo gioco e quasi quasi mi
metta giocare a warcraft tipo c'è ma non
ho mai visto la mente un gioco così
dettagliato fatto in unity c'è il
confronto sneijder non è niente per
esempio bene un po un portatile c'è
anche windows xp no hpa no è
semplicemente la marca del computer o
bruciamo ok
cosa devo fare non lo so a wind ecco
windows windows cola o windows
professionali z ragazzi questo uscirà
nel 2030 lo sappiamo già windows x2
tastiere e no una tastiera due monitor
fantastico
ok ma perché ti devi nasco basse ci
rinuncio ragazzi c'è il personaggio o è
un deviato mentalmente o gli piace
semplicemente non scontarsi sotto le
scrivanie e non ha senso bene cosa una
stampante canon non mi stupirebbe se
iniziasse a stampare basta nascondersi e
non ha senso
ok
andiamoci di qua prima che questo
iniziano a scaldarsi sotto tutte le
scrivanie porcia in un po d'acqua
mi serve so se te lo devi proprio a
scrocco senza bicchiere live
perfetto una caffettiera o perfetto ho
preso il caffè meglio tornare lavoro
avevi bisogno proprio del caffè solo ma
non c'era 20 nessuno qui dentro
ok però vorrei merlo il caffè no no devi
beh se voi mi spiegate come non fa
rovesciarsi così certi posto vabbè
dettagli a parte noi torniamo indietro
ci sono anche le banane in frigo c'è
qualcosa ragazzi oddio mag hamburger è
una pizza che è tutto meno che pizza
sembra vomito surgelato perfetto latina
aperta latte scaduto probabilmente da
secoli forchetta arma di difesa
questa mi serve ragazzi essendo un
videogioco horror ancora non è successo
nulla però vedremo cioè non hai da ok
vado con una lentezza che non avete idea
faccio che tagliare finché non arrivò
l'iva dai arrivo ciò che è successo
cos'è
oddio ice il ju boss di wendy dai type
this non l'hai fatto tu stai tranquillo
perché sono seduto prima errori davanti
cioè non ha senso e non l'hai scritto tu
tra l'altro c'è anche world fantastico
tanto non posso far niente usciamo bello
bello mi piace no ragazzi sta diventando
inquietante ragazzi c'è una cosa in
particolare che voglio farvi vedere non
è per essere più inquietante però giuro
è così allora voi guardate guardate un
secondo il tappetino per il mouse dove
dette ragazzi il tappetino del mouse
ok guardate il mio
uguale cazzo mi sto pagando addosso
ragazzi giuro
se domani torno e mi trovo una frase
scritta cucino i computer faccio un
salto che è meglio che registri mentre
torna mentre torna a casa non cosa devo
fare adesso però ok
oddio che ne sfruttato un braccio prima
non avevo le braccia ragazzi adesso mi è
spuntato un braccio è una penna cos'è è
un'arma di difesa si perché la penna
questa qui ce l'ho anch'io uguale vedete
questa penna qui è esattamente uguale a
quella che ciò io
vabbè comunque proseguiamo vai non ci
farà niente nessuno così sono armato
fino ai denti
la la porta del bagno ragazzi lo davo
lasciata aperta
l'avevo chiuso la porta del bagno
credo poi non ne sono sicuro permesso ce
ne sono
oddio che è successo è uscita dalla
carta igienica una chiave figo perché è
uscita dalla carta igienica babbo va
bene abbiamo una chiave che che era qui
dentro dentro l'area la carta igienica
perfetto costa chiave cosa c'è scritto
robert oddio che è successo sia si sia
aperto che è successo si è aperto il
telo cioè si è tirato sul costo del
proiettore fantastico no vabbè questa
ragazzi la devo capire tra l'altro qui
non c'era entrato prima ci proviamo ma
io ho aperto qualsiasi cosa acceso tutto
tanto non ed erika cosa stia facendo
bene ok non c'è niente che succede ti
nascondi nella scatola a no qua vicino a
perfetto pensavo volesse chiudersi
dentro la scatola no perché sarebbe un
ottimo nascondiglio lasciatelo dire sta
porta qui non si apre ok è riuscita bene
mentre un attimo qua dentro che si è
aperto il cosa senza motivo
che succede le sedie possedute perché
che è successo c'è un telefono lo sento
solo io telefono no c'è un telefono che
squilla ragazzi cè un telefono che
squilla più proviene tipo dalla mia
stanza montano ovunque faccio di nuovo
un taglio se non ci metta di nuovo re ok
ho usato la chiave però il telefono ha
smesso di squillare senza motivo che non
era questo che succede cos'è knox on the
door robertson di mons
i talking about cos'è sto muore ma un
pianoforte
[Musica]
da dove viene la camera mia ragazzi
così s'è chiusa si è chiuso qualcosa
ragazzi si è chiuso world
e si è accesa la radio box a turi meyer
ed io non lo so bene usciamo pronto
pizza
va beh noi riusciamo perché non idea di
che cosa debba fare qui si è chiuso
allora ricapitolando
c'è una frase strana scritta su quel
muro si è chiuso world
il mio collega scomparso misteriosamente
non so quando
ora non so cosa fare perfetto giriamo in
casa finché non trovo qualcos'altro no
più che altro voglio provare uscire
dalla porta su in fondo perché prima era
è volata una sedia a caso non c'è non
c'è neanche tirato un futuro da e
proprio volata da sola cioè succedono
cose o anormali ciechi cos'è quella roba
fuori porca [ __ ]
si sa però che cazzo è successo si è
aperto tutto si è aperto tutto quanto
ragazzi senza motivo bello mi spiegate
adesso che cazzo è successo no questo
non lo capite ragazzi avevo visto tipo
qualcosa di fare ancora sto telefono e
che palle ok stavolta ci arriva la
cornetta prima che finisci di chiamare
stronzo vai pronto pizza
ok ragazzi era soltanto pubblicità credo
noi andiamocene perché è stato veramente
inquietante quello quel palloncino c era
prima
no no non c'era prima col palloncino o
sbaglio no non c'era me lo ricordo bene
si era un solo tipo spostata le sedie ma
non c'era nessun palloncino cosa fai mi
fai scherzi palloncino tu mi fai del
male lo so sei cattivo mi vuoi prendere
alle spalle che cazzo è successo oddio è
spuntato qualcuno non me lo aspettavo
questi ragazzi è diventato un fantasma
il palloncino il palloncino ragazzi sta
prendendo il sopravvento
è lui l'artefice di tutto lo so e lui
che mi ha spiato fino adesso è lui che
mi scrive sul computer ragazzi state
alla larga dei palloncini sono
pericolosi davvero bene qua è chiuso ok
lander
oddio che cazzo è c'è qualcuno in fondo
bene bene bene viene via via via via via
ok ragazzi ok chiudiamo cosa sta
succedendo vi si sta sconquassando il
monitor
mi avevi l'anas conta sconditi ma
scanditi sotto la scrivania perfetto
[Musica]
ragazzi non so che cosa sta succedendo
il mio monitor ma non è ok perfetto se
n'è andato check my lover cos'è jo jo
brauer
cos'è questa nota non lavora ma c'era
prima no perché non nuovo vista
brauer cosa vuol dire drawer non mi
ricordo cosa vuol dire trovo e ragazzi
aspetta un attimo che vedo un secondo su
google
brauer cassetto adrower vuol dire
cassano mi ricordavo ragazzi giuro ok ci
siamo cassetto cassetto light is your
friend o cos'è questa roba the light is
your friend ho capito ho preso cos'è
oddio una torcia ma ama si prende con
spazio ma non lo sapevo ragazzi ci hanno
sostato niente batteria è meglio
guardare
per cercare il batterio che lo trovare
batterie dato ai ragazzi forse intendeva
questa torcia come amica c'è questa luce
è qui che torcia
bene devo trovare delle batterie
batterie batterie per la torcia batterie
per la torcia batte addio o di chiffon
che cazzo è successo si sono accesi
monitor perché si sono accesi i monitor
ok non voglio far domanda e usciamo di
qua
sì si può aprire cassetta no allora non
ci sono pil e via io ho bisogno di pile
non so neanche cosa mi serve la luce
perché mi perché ci vedo però mi servono
pile di qua c'è anche un cassetto sì
forse di qua
a che cosa è successo
grazie successo pile duracell fantastico
[Musica]
ok bene flashlight fammi usare la non
abbastanza battere quante ne servono di
batterie ragazzi mi spiegate che cazzo è
successo al mio schermo
cos'è successo allo schermo
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] che oddio oddio di aiuto
con la penna la penna che perfetto tutto
a posto dalla penna ha risolto il
problema
[Musica]
cazzo che è successo di nuovo
oddio no no no no però così no ma ci
piace a [ __ ] porca [ __ ] via via
perché c'è [ __ ]
no no no no no no no no cammino più
veloce sembri un bradipo in calore mamma
mia
allora adesso andiamo a farci conoscenza
tanto è mia amica
io ho una penna una penna game over man
oddio che è successo no no perché la mia
persona non ha funzionato
cosa devo fare e vabbè non ho capito
ragazzi ma bisogna così non voglio più
toccarlo
se volete scaricarlo anche se dubito lo
trovate in descrizione servito vi è
piaciuto lasciato mi piace al video e
anche la pagina di facebook che trovate
in descrizione per rimanere aggiornati
sui prossimi video
se non siete ancora iscritti al canale
iscrivetevi e ci vediamo prossimo video
dalla ragazzi